The Joe Rogan experience.
We're here to talk about what the is happening to the restaurant industry during
this pandemic and how crazy it is. Um, you know,
I I've talked about this before, but having you guys on,
so you could say firsthand what it's been like to you and what this experience
has been like and how poorly it's been handled. Just,
I want to give people a sense of this at home.
What it's like from two men who have made their living in the hospitality and
restaurant industry. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you want to.
Well, no, the funny thing is it's like, we're the rule followers.
We're the ones that are used to handling the health department.
We're the ones that are used to, you know, doing everything that, you know,
from a safety standpoint, right.
And now we're the ones that are being crushed or being picked on.
So to speak by that's the way a lot of people in the industry feel because we're
the ones that are being shut down in a city where a lot of other businesses
are remaining open, like malls, distribution centers,
Markus stores. I mean, you can go to a mall and go shopping.
You can go on an airplane from LA to New York,
take your mask off and eat and that's okay,
but you can't eat outdoors in a restaurant in LA that's following
social, distancing, all the health guidelines. I mean, we know our business.
And so it's been really hard since what it started, March 15th.
We, we shut down. Um, we were then told to put glass in between our,
our boots. So we did that. We opened for about 10 days. Um,
we did UV lights in the, in the, in the air conditioning systems.
Absolutely. And then we built patios. Um,
I've personally spent $250,000 abiding by the rules that were set forth by
the state, by the County, by the governors, by by everybody.
And then it just kind of be shut down is really, really difficult.
And it's not about me and it's not about my restaurant and it's not about John.
It's not about it's about the employees.
It's about the dishwashers and the busboys and the servers that live day to day
on the money that they make at the restaurant. It's their livelihood.
It's how they feed their families.
They send money back to the countries that they came from. You know,
this is a larger issue.
And the reason it's a larger issue is one little restaurant. Like Craig's,
we have 90 employees, a furniture store might have five or six.
So when you shut down an industry like that,
it really has a huge economic impact.
And then it has a social impact because we all love to eat.
It's the one thing we have in common. We like to get together as people.
Giant fan of restaurants. I mean,
that's one of my favorite things to do is to go out, to eat and living in LA.
It was so frustrating. It was, it was bizarre. It doesn't make sense.
Now when you guys get the, when they tell you what's shutdown or what's open,
is there anyone you communicate with there?
Is there anyone that's involved in government that you have conversations with?
That's the biggest issue that we have is they refuse to communicate to any of
us. And I can't quite figure out why we hear about it on the news.
We've we've joined with about 40, 30,
40 other like main owners. You know, that that are all in the area.
And I think it's the one thing that's kind of a silver lining in all.
This is that we've all teamed up to kind of like try to figure out what's going
on. But we find out about it from the news and we have to just make these moves
within 24 hours. It's, it's absolutely absurd. And we've reached out.
I reached out to Newsome. I reached out to Garcetti and they do nothing.
You know, they, they put you on phony task force. They lie, you know, they,
they, they have no idea how serious this is.
And I commend you for having us on. No one else wants to speak about it.
Everyone's too scared of backlash.
Well, what backlash, what?
I don't think they understand it at that level is crumbling.
Yeah. I think people are thinking it's black and white.
If you say anything somewhat negative,
they view you as you're anti COVID you're you're,
you're wanting to kill everybody. And that's not the case, right? Yeah.
But that's not the issue. So we're not denying that there's an issue.
We're not denying that people are getting sick.
We're not denying that there are, we all are in this together.
So how do you do it? Well, how do you do it? Smartly?
Where should we be spending money? Um,
a perfect example is they're doing rapid testing in certain areas.
So instead of losing all of this revenue,
why don't they invest in smart technology that has rapid testing
that allows people to go to a restaurant, get a rapid test, your positive,
your negative. And then you get to go into the restaurant.
We did hear today. Exactly. We got rapid test takes a day.
Everyone's a fine where we can sit down and have a conversation.
Have no paranoia. You could do that at a restaurant.
You could have the one I was telling you about Stubb's barbecue here in Austin,
where Dave Chappelle and I have been doing, we do 400 seats. We test everyone.
People get their way in advance. They test them, they get a COVID test,
which gives them a nice peace of mind, like, Oh great. I don't have it.
Then you get to sit down and enjoy a show and the place is packed.
And so the business is making money. Everyone's having a good time.
It's it's possible.
Well, that's what, that's what a lot of people are doing in LA. Right?
So they're having parties in LA and a lot of them are doing rapid testing
beforehand. So everybody gets a wristband that everybody in the party knows that
everybody's.
But this isn't the mayor threatening to shut those kinds of parties down.
You started to shut water off, like, like, and by the way, he's done it. Yeah.
Water and power, which we're living in like a dictatorship.
I literally feel like LA is like a third world country right now.
Never seen anyone.
Well, if you go to Venice or you go to downtown LA and you see the encampments,
it's bananas. I mean, third world countries wouldn't allow that.
Worse. This is some sort of dictatorship happening that, uh, we, we,
to me is a bigger picture. If, if, if other, uh,
governments, if other States counties,
cities see that they can just shut an industry down so easily,
get a name for themselves, get their name out there.
What's stopping everyone else from doing this.
It's new powers, catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free.
Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Jerry on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.